I'm going to give the state of play on  passenger name records member states  believe intra-eu flight should be  included to make the fight against  terrorism and also against trafficking  drug smuggling and a number of other  serious kinds of criminality more  effective we have discussed in detail  the data retention periods the council  originally asked for five years before  masking and the Parliament asked for 30  days so clearly compromised is needed on  both sides but whatever we agree so far  as I am concerned as rapid to it must be  proportionate and 12 months or above in  my mind could not be so we must make  sure that we are definitely ensuring the  exchange of relevant and useful  information that is a key issue if we  are to produce an instrument in my view  that is both effective and valuable we  made a lot of progress on key issues and  I'm confident that we will get a good  agreement by the end of this year